monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
ministreve monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur mes chers
collègues j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention les interventions de mes
excellents collègues Philipp bas et
Gérard Larcher qui ont respectivement
apporté un éclairage juridique et
institutionnel sur les dangers des
projets de loi que vous soumettez
j'approuve en tout point leur
démonstration je salue aussi les
intervention des présidents mesar zoketo
et
repsalem votre texte qui vise à
interdire le cumul d'un mandat
parlementaire avec toute fonction
exécutive locale même mineur monsieur le
ministre est excellent pour le Parti
socialiste il est excellent pour la
gauche parce qu'elle s'offre à moindre
frais é forme facile et populaire quitte
à ne pas réfléchir aux conséquences
institutionnelles de ce choix il est
excellent pour le Parti socialiste parce
qu'il flatte la fibre poujadiste qui
sommeille en chaque français quand il
est accablé par une situation économique
et sociale dont il ne voit pas l'issue
or quand un parti est en désamour dans
l'opinion qu' a-t-il de plus habile que
de jeter le discrédit sur l'ensemble de
la classe
politique il est aussi excellent pour le
président de la République parce qu'il
s'offre le luxe de se donner une image
de fermeté en résistant à une majorité
prétendument récalcitrante alors que
depuis le début de son quinquena il va
de reloncement en reloncement sur tous
ses engagements de
campagne il est excellent pour le
Premier ministre et son
gouvernement puisqu'il coupe désormais
tout lien entre l'élu et son territoire
puisque le parlementaire n'assiera plus
sa légitimité sur son rassignement local
le Parti socialiste pour investir les
candidats de son choix sans lien avec
les territoires des appart chic dont on
a tellement parlé aujourd'hui n'ayant
aucune légitimité que celle de la
commission d'investiture qui les aura
désigné et qui voteront sans brancher
les textes qui leur seront soumis
puisque les seules personnes qu'ils
auront à séduire seront les hiérarques
du PS et non plus les grands
électeurs il est excellent pour la
République des camarades puisque
dorénavant les candidats seront cooptés
dans un petit Sénacle de la rue de
Solferino cela sera particulièrement
vrai pour le Sénat puisque près de 3/4
des élus seront élus à la
proportionnelle n'importe quel camarade
pourrait être placé en début de liste
quitte à ce qu'il n'ait pas de lien avec
son territoire pour assurer son
élection c'est aussi excellent pour les
officines d'influence de la gauche qui
pouront faire voter les lois les plus
absurdes comme la réforme de la justice
insufflée par le Syndicat de la
magistrature ou la réforme de l'école
par les syndicats enseignant sans que
les parlementaires puissent faire
remonter la voix du
peuple mais il y a un autre point en
tant que sénateur de Paris que je
souhaite aborder c'est celui de
l'interdiction faite au maires
d'arrondissement et à leurs adjoint
d'être parlementaire je pourrais
éventuellement comprendre l'interdiction
de cumul pour des fonctions électives
excessivement prenantes comme pour le
maire d'une capitale de plus de 2
millions d'habitants ou pour de grandes
villes françaises à une époque vos
réflexions vous avez entraîné vers
l'idée de fixer un seuil de population
pour l'interdiction de cumuler une
fonction élective à défaut de trouver ce
seuil vous avez proposé une stricte
interdiction qui est déjà absurde pour
une petite commune mais qui devient
ridicule pour une mairie
d'arrondissement vous le savez monsieur
le ministre un maire d'arrondissement
est loin d'exercer la totalité des
compétences de son secteur et que dire
de ses adjoint je vous épagne
l'inventaire de la liste de ses
compétences mais tout à chacun c'est
bien qu'elle ne justifie pas que les
maires d'arrondissement soient traités
comme des maires de plein exercice
j'ajoute que dans le cas de Paris ce
n'est pas les temps de déplacement du
Parlement à la circonscription qui
prendront beaucoup de temps dans
l'agenda de l'élu sérieusement rien ne
peut justifier cette interdiction à part
peut-être votre volonté de niveler vers
le bas madame hiidalgo craint-elle à ce
point de ne pas exercer le leadership
sur ces troupes qu'elle s'ingénie à
s'assurer qu'aucun maire
d'arrondissement ne soit député ou
un maire d'arrondissement qui siège au
parlement ce n'est pas un handicap pour
Paris en interdisant aux grands élus
parisiens d'être parlementairire on
affaibli leur influence institutionnelle
en vérité monsieur le ministre la seule
vraie réforme serait comme on l'a déjà
dit dans cet hémicycle et à l'Assemblée
nationale de faire élire le maire de
Paris directement par les Parisiens et
le problème de cumul ne se poserait plus
merci